okay here's party pants now okay here we
are party pants is joining the party
[ __ ] friends these are dark tanks we now
know for a fact that scrambles the
missing cat is part of a larger
conspiracy we also know that the [ __ ]
freedom pals have more information about
this conspiracy than we do FAC maybe we
should just face it guys maybe freedom
pals have a better super franchise no
hey that's no way to talk mosquito the
only reason that freedom pals are ahead
of us right now is because their butt
bucket cheaters who sold out yeah but
freedom paths have dr. Kinison he can
read people's nice and bent reality yeah
cuz he just said that when we made up
our super powers he was like well I have
every power to do [ __ ] it everything you
think that's fair it's time for us to be
as dirty as f we'd have to know at the
Freedom House know how we ever gonna get
the help of freedom panel
we send a spy someone in our group who
pretends to want to switch side oh I
wonder who somebody who they don't know
very well I can get the new kid and said
I've got hacking abilities remember cuz
I'm the gadget to your class with the
tinkling ability known as chaos you just
saying that to get out of jail you
better let him go the new kid will need
him alright fine freedom house base okay
if he tries anything funny kill him man
okay cool if we're gonna go with Perez
the cast hey hey is that a professed
yeah that's a breakfast ah that's a put
a PI reference that has to be a per to
party yes top bad guys I've been away
for a few days I haven't been able to
play I was celebrating birthdays and
stuff but I'm really happy to be back
and playing cuz this game is so fun
there was no break for you guys so don't
worry actually probably was well anyway
we got to meet up with Professor chaos
well isn't this great we get to spend
some time talking to you there we go
excuse me I am NOT a boy okay I'm a
Scandinavian Swede a Mian
[Music]
where have you been mr. boo
hey Dad but I just didn't come home last
night but us your mom and I were worried
sick we could barely enjoy the movie
we're not gonna cut it mister and you
what's your name
you get seasick you don't escape
oh no I asked you a question yeah how do
we reply
sure buddy borrowing gather the flying
minion ingredients get the superhero
figurine cape get the rock okay okay
[Music]
well that was easy guess we can't do
that Jebus sure buddy what is this then
[Music]
my god be quiet please there we go
now I can grab it what else we need the
hamster
I shouldn't be hard right all right now
we got to craft the flying mitt what in
the world
Oh so cute oh my god okay we have the
flying minion what can he do though
escaped butters house
I'm all worried about this
[Music]
[Applause]
how do we escape hold l2 - okay okay so
we can do something now we get a lot of
these so here will fly up and bite the
wires no no oh no no no no I say no I
said no now why couldn't you just have
thrown him up whoopee indeed my butt can
do all kinds of school stuff
finally my butt is getting recognized
for its true talent and potential thank
you oh there's a shapes oh we can use
hey why are here yeah alright up yeah
yeah just got a text IRA hamster
[Music]
this is so weird
they're not doing it right
I guess I got it sticking another one
hold down I was doing it there you go
does that mean ha ha ha all right now
back oh oh a wrestling photo that's what
that was
yes of course can't seem to walk here
for some reason there we go
what we got something else in me a new
artifact perhaps think it's time some of
these are outdated aren't they
whoa look at that we're really strong
now ok or at a gay gay gay but that's
impossible I grounded you how could you
be here right now you have some kind of
ability to unground people whoever you
touch becomes ungrounded is that it yes
you're even not welcome here darling
[Music]
but Erstad are we gonna find him
nice defeat butters dead all right we
get the whole team here cool oh wow
your buddies can't join the fight until
you and ground them the ability iron
grind has to replace your ultimate power
in this fight
Oh what okay well let's start off oh no
I don't oh I see I can use it whenever I
want
there you go you're ungrounded I use
much dark black magic no not ever
granted peace ah shoot
yes a lot of health how many times do I
got to tell you Mike yeah okay I can't
walk there let's just unground these
guys alright lets unground the [ __ ]
[Music]
don't know if we can actually get out of
here oh we can we can switch places
[ __ ] has that ability this mate Stevie
damn good damage too
goddammit ah so dumb I need to use was
that a PewDiePie reference oh my god Wow
I don't believe it okay erratic Gabe
Gabe we're gonna keep using this one
[Music]
Jonah's gonna get grind ground grinders
grounded damn it how is he not dead yet
okay he's that now there you go thank
God we got him grounded for life
[Music]
that was fun fun fight we really messed
up this place didn't me oh we gotta go
to tokens house I don't know if we
should go back there okay he's supposed
to be x-men okay let's go to his Sergei
okay a.m. okay Oh Garrett schoo dark
minute here we go I did what's up this
is just tokhes house what do you mean I
am we can use well no we we hack it but
okay whatever you say I have to stand
over here for some reason
well that's messed up
I feel bad
hey that's kind of cool
[Music]
what are you doing here oh hey mr. Yun
well we were just hoping to speak with
dr. Timothy why the new kid wants to
switch franchises and I told him I
helped a new kid
thought you might end up here they're
here to spy on what Timothy is working
on I wonder - let's hear what they have
to say oh my god okay this is a fairly
shocking change of heart for you
professor you really wish to help the
new kids switch franchises well yeah
yeah you know we just thought that you
know your franchise in July will open it
but you know we just thought he should
switch because Cody friends plan isn't
going anywhere oh god see you kid came
to me and said my friends a coda for
that set it out without you get anything
the aluminum foil on his helmet seems to
be blocking my abilities they can't see
what you've been working on back there
what if the new kid really wants to
switch we can see if the new kids
intentions are pure we're sending tough
aware on a very important mission today
you can help him with that mission I
don't need backup especially not a new
easy tough remember the freedom pals
model how does the understand
retribution but with inclusion I'll send
you the details on the mission when you
get there we can begin in the meantime I
must get back to my work
what is he's working on alright so we
joined the freedom pouch now that's
right freedom Pam does do they have a
shop here's one Mac five nice training
room what goes on in the training room
it's just a room
glad we glad we did that
[Music]
shit's goin so fast in this town
I'm cabal its viper suit the Viper one
is cool then you know it was the Viper
[Music]
now these are all cool damn it look at
that it's that not dope huh
no stupid how dope is that huh y'all
stick your makeup you kind of remind me
of my sister new kid that is weird urge
to protect you it looks like Kenny a
little bit I have this weird urge to
protect you that's the social justice
more yeah anybody real proud of you meet
the freedom palace at the South Park
Senior Center okay okay all right let's
check it out we're probably gonna have
to beat up some old people but you know
what I say old people might as well be
not living I came out a little weird
okay every right Amy me I'd catch up on
this up bug yesterday that it's still so
gay man it's a very important mission
are you sure you're up to it yes thank
you
oh my god
I'd love to play my triangle my triangle
goes bling when I am sad I love to hear
my triangle go it cheers me up and it
makes me smile you suck I'm sorry folks
this kids new play my triangle my
triangle goes dude I'm killing it the
triangle I love to play my mandolin my
mandolin goes I love to hear my mandolin
go it cheers me up and makes me smile oh
my god my mandolin my mandolin goes oh
[Music]
or goes I love to play my bugle horn my
arugula horn goes oh oh oh I should have
seen that coming
I love to hear my bugle horn go
[Music]
disgusting and it makes me smile why am
i enjoying this yeah what'd I tell you
we gotta gotta kill some old people oh
[Music]
this is AG okay it's a special objective
it should be fine what are they gonna do
knockers back ah no ah he's so annoying
a Jewish scroll next time I'll show you
what I really meant to do oh great let's
try this
pretty powerful we have this that's
right our all people that's a strong one
no ill ill ill they're all making me
grossed out I don't like this
[Music]
doc this is mysterion
we had some trouble but the mission is
complete nice work everyone new kid
congratulations thank you a member of
freedom palace ah that was the big
tonight on our mission to the police
station we've ascertained that the
police are being paid off by whoever's
running crime in the city that's right
we believe we'll find the answers to
what's going on there welcome to the
team Fred thank you tonight
don't tell anyone we're going to the
police station well I might just I might
just tell some people I don't know why
I'm loyal to the [ __ ] friends but I
guess I guess this is the way the cookie
crumbles is this your own okay dear but
Lord stop recent triangle playing of
what what in the world okay we got to go
back to [ __ ] lair you know when someone
says they're gonna do something and you
think you can trust him but then they
don't and they're super lame instead
don't sub Grammy dick thank you
[Music]
I really appreciate it we gotta help pay
the minions
should we do that let's do that
can we fast travel yes we can't run
gotta go fast it's loading screens are
intense man I've wished more and more I
played on PC man but goddamn is that on
tail it looks like a poop whatever
alright here we are at the bank oh yeah
we gotta use our bus okay
[Music]
real superpowers look at that no
fake-ass superpowers sorry one second
let's check out the bank this is the
person you wish to have cosign for you
well that's correct
see I hired a bunch of minions to help
me destroy the town but my plan didn't
actually come to fruition so I'm unable
to pay the minions at this time all
right well what we can do is set up an
LLC for you which we can use to fund a
money market account co-signed by your
friend here whose house we can put a
lien on to an overseas investment and
it's what's gone your friends house it's
got owned by a company in Hong Kong down
thank you you have a nice day I didn't
mean to get my friend's house taken away
yeah you're not too good at this
economic stuff huh perhaps your friend
should play yeah you play new kid round
and round she goes where she stops
nobody knows all right Kate try your
luck
what come on carmine carmine carmine
[Music]
skills in it skills stop the wheel what
in the world is happening
I guess we keep spinning
just don't get bankrupt don't get bank
closed skill stop the wheels pressed to
stop no whammies insider trading
Joey bean few I ever did well agile
investing bonus triple value on the next
uh okay
whoa we're in low class now look at that
we're rich man winner winner chicken
dinner yeah boy I can just got a loan
for over eighty thousand dollars to pay
immigrant workers their salaries you can
be a winner too just keep on trying
people here's your check it what in the
world was that can we play again that
was fun I was a good there's a [ __ ]
that's right it'd take the judge we're
mad for Mary okay let that make sense
come on boys let's show them some
minutes made in America all right let's
just kick those guys asses well what we
can summon minions now we can summon the
Mexicans that's awesome
he took our minion jab he took our
married
I mean it's pretty good that's a
microaggression yeah how dare you say
that there's nothing wrong with being a
minion and they could still build stuff
if they want you okay all right you're a
good tank you're a more mature tank out
back I heard a little bit Oh a car and
they're even in on it run you down don't
[ __ ] move
I mean we did move then me
my god our minion sticking a lot of
damage hey we're did in okay nice we
need to level up a little bit we're a
bit under level so it's good that we do
these extra quests and stuff isn't that
fun this is what you want in life okay
good job reading between the lines that
gentleman's clearly certificate of what
it's safe
damn it talk to the [ __ ] in the [ __ ]
lair
[Music]
let's see if there's some more requests
that we can do just to level up a love
bit you know I'm saying you know I'm
saying you know I'm saying let's go to
windy she's close by anyway
my minions and I will fight by your side
any time but ho
hashtag chaos thank you for that hashtag
we haven't seen like anything too crazy
yet so I'm thinking maybe that's the
stuff they say for the side quests oh
god I don't want to go to the
appropriate bathroom oh I see okay
all right I think I know which one oh
[Music]
maybe I know but that's where I am oh no
it's got to be the hardest part about
living life as a boy your bathrooms are
disgusting anyway I got a problem this
is a micro stranger and stranger but
nobody will listen to me I started
cross-referencing everyone's instagrams
whoever did this has to pay I'm going to
the mobile company to find out what
happened I know where that is d Mobile
because they are dicks here it is yeah
no all right are you ready to do this
yes let's go find out what's wrong with
this place
[Music]
no that's my enemy the people who worked
here last week
we're glad people Wow 5 gigabyte but
crap people is my mortal enemy this
would be hard no crappy [ __ ] man this is
so brilliant seriously any time you try
and just get a data plan they always
just put some weird stuff on you that
you don't want
well at least wind is strong oh he has
savings for us how nice as long as the
crab people don't touch it we might be
okay yeah they're so disgusting I hate
them
oh no no their manager Oh Employee of
the Month manager can't crap every oh
damn though we got to defeat the king
crap but how he's too strong it's
impossible Mexican mobility is her
strong we can still attack it from here
we should probably finish him off first
we ducks Wow oh wait he can summon No oh
and he can heal it's where that's really
bad for us okay all right okay now
they're really weak
yeah okay I'm working on it all right
Wendy
working on it there we go project your
man out your crappy ball ah damn I'm
working on E
hopefully you can't heal himself
just remember crap people is my mortal
enemy will all die crap people yes screw
those crab people
screw the manatee hey that's fun I'm
glad thank you call girl I don't know
what those things were but they smelled
like crab and kissed like people how can
we repay you just get my phone working
again all right yes yes of course call
girl thanks for saving the mobile store
once again thanks new kid but I have a
feeling this isn't over
you snow crab come well do Wendy and we
can loot them that is an efference I
love the side quest this is so fun and
there was law it was that actually
lowered playing all right let's check
out the cones they're not fair [ __ ]
around
I mean enough [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] believed a
building around am i right it's right
there
what's the passcode now no girls allowed
okay did it now great job here up those
freedom posers have no idea you [ __ ]
them over
alright guys listen up but lord has
discovered that the freedom pals are
infiltrating the police station tonight
we have to get there before they do the
police station I can't take down the
police are you crazy do it we can't do
that guys
because at approximately 10:30 a.m. this
morning class II was arrested by the
police
Yuda
we have to help her get this we made a
promise if we let freedom pals go do
this on their own then where the
douchebag franchise they say we are but
why would freedom house work with us
don't forget the new kid is all
buddy-buddy with freedom pals now but
Lord can trick them into an assault on
the lower level of the police station
and meanwhile we'll sneak in and bust
classi out you're probably gonna get the
Freedom House killed and then whose
superhero franchise would be number one
we can't make a promise
classy everyone get home and get to bed
we have a big job to do tonight that'll
be all but Lord go home and wait to hear
from the freedom pass
thank you no no no no no are you [ __ ]
kidding look I'm sorry about what
happened to your mother I know that you
want closure but oh no I guess I don't
know how I feel you're right you're
right maybe you should have just one way
one we're playing a carrot a carrot a
care
[Music]
perhaps a plant man sir like poison ivy
really catchy tune man crime with no
real superpowers Gadgeteer let's stir
gadgets here you're laying in bed you
heard your mom screaming walk down to
the hallway is it gadgets here hero you
knew you can answer these and shooters
with whatever inventions you had in
store first you decided to change the
batter field to your advantage with your
straight shooter turret gun look kid we
aren't here to play
[Music]
the intruder noted the threat that your
gadget presented in sweeping took it out
okay but you had way more gadgets where
that came from
I have more gadget my god what is this a
dummy ignorant of the power behind your
creations well that seems pretty useless
I see oh it's all about this oh damn
that's pretty good shooters moved in to
retaliate but you're an exercise is a
gift that keeps on giving
the remaining intruder moved in without
any of your inventions available he was
able to get into credit but now we have
our olds okay let's see how what they
all dis it's a drone nice
you kids and your damn toys what about
the alien everybody okay you read your
parents door before anything bad could
happen you ran inside to protect your
mouth but you were too late your dad
totally butchered ha ha must be tearing
you apart inside how people can do that
to other people I just I'm so sorry
anyway we've got work to do tonight I
see you at the police station there's
nothing more to talk about I'll be in
touch tonight after your parents think
you're sleeping yes we'll change into
our custom but in the next episode thank
you guys so much for watching another
one I hope you enjoyed it I'll see you
tomorrow again we're back on track daily
sorry I missed one but it's always smart